so sieht die ideale Kandidatin aus sie
steht gerade
lächelt strahlend hat keine Narben und
perfekte Nägel
es muss alles stimmen für ihr großes
Ziel Flugbegleiterin werden
ich würde so gerne Stewardess werden
dann kann ich viele Orte sehen mich
jeden Tag schick anziehen das liebe ich
so sehr
kommt selten vor dass wir bei einem
großen Unternehmen in China exklusiv
drehen können doch diesmal haben die
Behörden grünes Licht gegeben wir dürfen
bei einem Casting in Wuhan dabei sein
nach dem Ende der Reisebeschränkungen
stellt heinan Airlines wieder ein und
wird von Anfragen regelrecht überrannt
Airlines hat dieses Jahr bereits 30
auswahlveranstaltungen gemacht
bei uns sind 40.000 Bewerbungen
eingegangen Wuhan haben wir als Ort
gewählt weil es hier viele berühmte
Universitäten gibt mit gut ausgebildeten
Studierenden
die Kandidaten müssen erstmal ihre
Fingerabdrücke nehmen lassen dann geht's
zum Messen das Casting dauert drei Tage
700 Bewerberinnen und Bewerber nur 10%
werden eine Stelle bekommen die
Anspannung ist gewaltig
heiß die Konkurrenz ist hart ich kann
nur mein bestes geben ich hoffe dass
jeder irgendwann seinen Traumjob finden
wird
ob Balingen ihren Traum bald leben kann
dazu später mehr für viele junge
Menschen in China geht es zurzeit nicht
um ihren Traumberuf sondern darum
überhaupt irgendeinen Job zu bekommen
der Frust ist groß
hier stehen sie an wie bei einem
Popkonzert warten eine Stunde und mehr
auf den Einlass mitten im Regen
doch statt feiern und tanzen gehen Sie
zum lama-tempel in Peking ich treffe
hier viele Schüler und Studierende beten
dass es in China eher etwas untypisches
denn hier gibt es eigentlich nur eine
Institution an die die Menschen glauben
sollen die Kommunistische Partei
umso erstaunlicher dass so viele junge
Leute hier vor Buddha Knien und beten
unser ich bete dass ich einen Job finde
seit meinem Schulabschluss tue ich mich
sehr schwer mit dem Bewerbungen ich
suche schon eine ganze Weile nach einer
Stelle die Jobsituation ist angespannt
es ist auch hart mit ansehen zu müssen
wie meine Mitschüler damit kämpfen
jetzt zünden sie Räucherstäbchen an
suchen Beistand bei höheren Wesen
verneigen sich fliehen
die Partei die sonst für alles sorgt
kann Ihnen keine Sicherheit mehr
garantieren in diesem Jahr wurden in
China bereits dreimal so viele
Eintrittskarten für Tempel verkauft wie
im vergangenen die Hälfte der Besucher
ist Mitte 20 oder jünger das ist neu
ich möchte wissen wie es den jungen
Leuten geht bei unseren Gesprächen höre
ich immer wieder dass die Jobsuche für
viele eine große psychische Belastung
ist
letztes Jahr habe ich mich auf 60
Stellen beworben und wurde zu 20
Gesprächen eingeladen dieses Jahr ist es
noch schlimmer 100 Bewerbungen und nur
10 Einladungen
die Gebetsmühle drehen hoffen
dann seit der corona-pandemie erholt
sich die Wirtschaft in China in vielen
Branchen weiter nur schleppend die Krise
trifft junge Leute besonders hart jeder
fünfte unter 25 Jahren ist zurzeit
arbeitslos und das sind nur die
offiziellen Zahlen ein Rekord hoch dazu
kommen so viele Hochschulabsolventen wie
noch nie 11,6 Millionen die auf den
Arbeitsmarkt drängen an den Unis gab es
in den letzten Jahren einen Stau
Prüfungen wurden pandemiebedingt
verschoben
auf die von John ich treffe ihn im
Tempel Innenhof und er erzählt mir dass
er Softwareentwicklung studiert auch er
ist hierher gekommen um zu beten
beim Räucherstäbchen anzünden erklärt er
mir dass es eigentlich Teil des
chinesischen Traums ist das immer mehr
junge Leute überhaupt studieren können
dieses Jahr gibt es viel mehr
Uni-Absolventen als in den Jahren davor
das ist Rekord und das ist gut weil es
zeigt dass es immer mehr gebildete
Menschen in China gibt
es ist sein großes Versprechen
Staatschef skijim sicherte China weniger
Armut und mehr Bildung zu doch für die
junge Generation wird dieser Traum
gerade zum Albtraum denn in den
Staatsmedien formuliert ist Ski heute so
erst Bitterkeit was er damit meint geht
dahin wo er China und der Partei dienen
könnt damit meinte auch dass junge Leute
von den Städten aufs Land ziehen und
auch Jobs annehmen sollen die Ihren
Ansprüchen nicht entsprechen
doch einige Jugendliche lassen sich das
nicht gefallen und Posten in den
sozialen Netzwerken diesen Song
der fröhliche kommt die Idee ein
Arbeitsloser studierte der lieber
verhungert heißt dass er einfachen
Tätigkeiten nachgeht
vier Millionen Internet Aufrufe nur
einem Tag
doch die Unzufriedenheit der jungen
Leute sie ist gefährlich für den
Führungsanspruch der Partei das Video
von Kongi wird umgehend zensiert und
gelöscht
doch auch morgen will sich nichts
vorschreiben lassen wir treffen ihn auf
einer der wenigen Jobbörsen in chinas
Hauptstadt er hat gerade einen Master in
bekleidungsmarketing in der Tasche und
will auch als solche Arbeiten
studiert hat morgen in Südkorea früher
galt ein Studium im Ausland als goldenes
Ticket für den chinesischen Arbeitsmarkt
doch jetzt fragt sich morgen ob er nicht
lieber im Ausland geblieben wäre
der Arbeitsmarkt ist da okay etliche
Studierende die mit mir den Abschluss
gemacht haben haben schon einen Job
gefunden
für morgen ist die Suche dagegen mühsam
nur wenige Unternehmen stellen zurzeit
ein auch auf der Jobbörse
drei Jahre Pandemie haben die Wirtschaft
auf der ganzen Welt in Schieflage
gestürzt
jetzt müssen wir das ausbügeln
wird schon irgendwie
[Musik]
zurück zum Flugbegleiter Casting bei den
e hat es in die letzte Runde geschafft
noch einmal müssen sie und die anderen
Kandidaten sich vor der Jury beweisen
alles wie ein Uhrwerk mit viel Geduld
und militärischer Disziplin
ich hoffe so so sehr dass ich diesen Job
bekomme hoffentlich bestehe ich ich
würde meine allerbestes geben als
Stewardess
etwa 70 glückliche haben in Wuhan einen
Job als Flugbegleiter ergattern können
und dürfen sofort ihr neues firmenfoto
für Hanna Airlines schießen für beide
hier ist dieser Traum heute geplatzt sie
muss weitersuchen wie hunderttausende
andere junge Menschen in China in diesem
Jahr